my understanding of what microstrategy
is doing is you basically have
articulated and highlighted two separate
strategies we have a software business
that we're going to continue to try to
grow uh drive cash flow and serve our
customers from a business intelligence
standpoint and then we have a treasury
strategy which is uh we're going to use
bitcoin to protect our purchasing power
and our assets that are actually sitting
on the balance sheet and those two
strategies combined make up the business
and you know obviously the market has
found it incredibly attractive given uh
what the stock price has done over the
last year or so if your apple computer
you've got two strategies you can pursue
to get in the digital economy one
strategy is you just buy 50 billion
dollars of bitcoin
and three people can do it and if the
three people did it then your stock
becomes a bitcoin derivative apple stock
becomes a bitcoin derivative and if
bitcoin moves up at 100 a year right
you're generating 50 billion dollars a
year of shareholder value three people
50 billion shareholder value right it's
very simple strategy the harder strategy
is you start building uh bitcoin
protocol
or lightning protocol
into all your other products you can
build it into the iphone you can build
it in the icloud you can you know you
can build it into all of your other
services you know and uh they all have
merit
and that's an operating strategy and at
that at some point that starts to um
that starts to correlate your revenues
to the growth of of the digital asset
economy and the growth of bitcoin
so
uh and and and all that both of those
are rational
what's not rational
what's not rational is um
is to require that all your customers
pay you in bitcoin
and stop taking dollars right right you
can control what you do with your
balance sheet and you can control what
your strategy is but implementing on
your customers or to rewire all your
all your back in accounting system so
and it's unnecessary right it's it's not
the right way so
like coming back to
to my view of the world i mean i i think
my view of the world is
we want to find the path of least
resistance to to fix everything
and that means that means uh
looking at every single part of the
economy every country will be better if
they had some bitcoin
uh cities can uh
can be improved if they buy bitcoin if a
city buys bitcoin and they issue bonds
the bond becomes a bitcoin-backed bond
right it becomes a derivative of bitcoin
so i'm not against bonds right i'm not
the guy saying we shouldn't have bonds
we should have bonds right if the junk
bond index is four percent and you can
issue a bitcoin back bond at six percent
it's good for the people that have
trillions of dollars locked up in bonds
it's good for bitcoin it's good for
everybody in the middle
right we could say
we can take the orthodox draconian view
which is bond should go away and bitcoin
should replace them overnight but it's
not it's not possible but it's not even
a better view right yeah a better view
is
is
you take your bank and you start
handling
bitcoin and you take your mobile app and
you build lightning into the mobile app
and you take your company and
and uh and you buy it and
you buy bitcoin and the reason i don't
really think it's a threat
to the bitcoin ethos is because
ultimately
none of these people can control bitcoin
it's like people worry like i so i have
seven billion dollars or eight billion
dollars of bitcoin i don't have any more
power
anybody else
right and and in fact
the only sentiment that's grown in my
mind as my bitcoin position has grown is
i don't want anybody to change it like
don't mess it up right
right so i think that is
i'm not threatened if a government buys
bitcoin it wouldn't be bad for bitcoin
right i'm not threatened if a company
buys it if a bank buys it
yeah and here i guess there is one
there's one point worth making
if you're um
if your portfolio is 100 bitcoin
you don't have any conflicts of interest
the you know the debate of whether or
not people use square cash app paypal
robinhood coinbase binance or buy the
etf or buy it through fidelity or it
doesn't really matter to you
right it doesn't matter to you whether
they buy microstrategy stock to get
bitcoin exposed doesn't matter to you
right you're just holding the underlying
asset
if you decide that you want to get in
the business of selling hardware wallets
or if you run an exchange or if you
provide advice and if
now you have a conflict of interest so
now you're you're a bitcoin entrepreneur
and
maybe
like
if you're issuing if you're tether and
you're issuing stable coins
you don't want j.p morgan to issue
stable coins
it's conflict of interest right
competition right i mean if the feds say
you have to get an fdic license now you
got to jump through a hurdle now you
need general counsels you need to
actually pay lawyers you have to do
stuff right you have to have nexus you
have to have insurance it's harder so
so there are a lot of things that are
happening in the economy
they're good for bitcoin they're just
not good for every entrepreneur in the
crypto ecosystem